DAYS AWAY AND YOU WILL
RIGHTFULLY DECIDE THE FUTURE OF
THIS GREAT DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
JOINING US NOW HOUSE
MINORITY WHIP SKEWED
STEVE SCALISE.
MATT GAETZ, GOOD TO SEE YOU BOT
BOTH.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, THERE'S NO
STOPPING IT.
THIS IS ALL WE HEARD.
WE HAVE RUN MONTAGES.
2016, 2017, 2018 AND ALL THROUGH
2019.
IMPEACH THROUGH THEIR FAVORITE
WORD.
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES IN
YOUR VIEW?
>> THE CONSEQUENCES ARE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A STAIN ON
NANCY PELOSI'S LEGACY.
THIS WAS AN IMPEACHMENT IN
SEARCH OF A CRIME THEY NEVER
FOUND A CRIME, SEAN.
THE RADICAL BASE WANTED
IMPEACHMENT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT DID
ANYTHING WRONG WITH SO THEY WENT
AFTER IT ANYWAY.
INSTEAD OF DOING THE THINGS THEY
COULD HAVE BEEN DOING TO WORK
WITH THIS PRESIDENT TO LOWER
DRUG PRICES, TO ADDRESS THE MANY
OTHER PROBLEMS IN OUR COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LIVE WITH.
IT WOULDN'T BE THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY, SEAN, BY THE WAY, THAN
IMPEACHMENT OF A PRESIDENT
HAPPENED ON A PARTY LINE VOTE.
THE ONLY BIPARTISAN VOTE WILL BE
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT AND AGAIN,
THAT'S GOING TO BE A STAIN ON
PELOSI'S LEGACY AS SPEAKER.
>> Sean: MATT GAETZ, YOU ARE
WATCHING THIS UNFOLD.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THIS HAS BROUGHT THE REPUBLICAN
REPUBLICANS, PEOPLE LIKE
YOURSELF TO THE FOREFRONT
FIGHTING FOR WHAT TRUTH IS,
FIGHTING FOR DUE PROCESS.
THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE RAMMED
THIS THROUGH SO QUICKLY.
THEY ONLY HAD ONE FACT WITNESS,
ALL HEARSAY AND OPINION
WITNESSES.
IT'S REMARKABLE IN TERMS OF THE
DEPTH OF DEPRAVITY AND THE LACK
OF SERIOUSNESS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE BECAUSE
POLITICALLY THERE'S NO WAY THEY
GET AWAY WITH THIS WITHOUT
PAYING A PRICE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I SAID AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
RELEASED THE TRANSCRIPT OF HIS
PERFECTLY FINE CALL THE
NANCY PELOSI HAD BEEN
FUNCTIONALLY CAT FISHED AN
ILLEGITIMATE IMPEACHMENT.
TOMORROW WE WILL NOT WIN THE
VOTE BUT WE HAVE WON THE
ARGUMENT.
THE RESULT OF THAT IS GOING TO
BE WE ARE GOING TO WIN THE
ELECTION.
I KNOW ADAM SCHIFF'S DOG MAY NOT
BE NAMED IMPEACH BUT I THINK
IT'S THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
ARE GOING TO HAVE ADAM SCHIFF IN
THE DOGHOUSE WHERE THEY SEE THAT
OUR COUNTRY HAS BEEN DIVIDED AND
DISTRACTED WITH NO CRIME, NO